hey folks I'm Kurt Davina and joining me
today is Rob who had the great pleasure
of being able play Star Wars squadrons
and there's two really special things
about your position around your big star
Wars fan you got a Lego behind you I see
it in the distance that's that's not
messing around that's when the ultimate
collection that's that's a really sick
Lego I'll get to him later and you have
flight time you you you fly real planes
I I did I have to go back and get my
license but I have about 85 hours of
actual flight time now but that's the
amazing thing is that you're the perfect
person to tell me what this game is like
so let's start from beginning what was
the basic of what you experienced but
what were the things you were most
excited about with your time with it I
played two and half hours I would say
there were three things about what I saw
or as an overview is I played like the
prologue and single-player it was okay
I played dogfighting your basic 5v5 mode
standard for combat flight sim and then
I played their kind of renowned original
fleet battle mode which is essentially
like destroyed the other teams flag ship
with like lines of tug and pole with
like a defensive line you know I mean
like take out their cruisers then you
get closer to the enemy flagship but the
biggest takeaway with this game is how
approachable and how much I enjoyed
right off the bat how the game felt and
hey you know as anyone would as far as
like getting refreshing themselves with
a Star Wars property is I play
battlefront 2 and going back to that
game like it was known for having a
really great star fighter mode and I did
enjoy that mode a lot a lot of people
did but I never felt the controls were
super tight here in Star Wars squadrons
like I always feel like I was going into
menus with battle frontier idea just at
the make it feel right to you just a
deadpan slider so it doesn't you know
you have like less precision or smaller
increments but here it was like off the
bat default like oh this feels really
good and the one thing I would say that
that you could you could kind of start
as a as a jumping-off point with how the
game feels and the controls and the
unique ways they're Tet they're tackling
this infamous problem what I'm getting
at is called the death loop which is
like
known in so many flight combat games
which is like I'm chasing you we're just
doing this and whoever's hand spasms or
gives out is the loser for him yeah is
the loser it's it's not ideal it's it
can get real boring like I'm never
playing games I'd be like you know what
just kill me and I'll just like
straighten out and just like wave like
because it's not fun so like that's a
problem it's an inherent problem for all
combat flight Sims here they have like a
multitude of really neat interesting
ideas to address that to briefly say you
know there are four types of ships
there's a fighter standard x-wing TIE
fighter ty interceptor faster a little
bit weaker but hard-hitting bomber you
know a heavy hitter strong will you
imagine like a y-wing behind me and then
support is kind of the new class which
is like I can just be a Thai Reaper or
the white sari the you wing from rogue
one which is like I will just and
through load on some customization I'll
just drop like energy pickups or bonus
shields and just like support my team so
this is so I mean that the individual
ships also act like their own classes
and yes you have your own role and what
it is you have to do depending on the
ship you choose yeah exactly and you can
get let's further yeah you can get
further until like loadouts and like I
just want my ship to be focused on
taking off enemy shields but you can
customize it already like but finally
back into the one of the coolest Simmons
things about this game and again solving
that like inherent death loop problem is
they introduced something called power
management which is depending on the
ship there are two well there are three
things with power management some ships
only have two aspects of what you can do
with power management and what they are
all three are engines lasers and shields
engines and lasers are the two inherent
ones that I'll talk about which are in a
situation given my scenario I can send
all my energy and power into just my my
lasers say I'm like you know what I'm in
I'm in this situation where I just want
to lay and hammer on a StarCruiser
I don't need my shields I don't need my
engines at this moment in time so I'm
shifting everything to make my
weapons beefier which is fun and it's
all the d-pad at least for the
controller or say I'm getting chased by
you and you're you're on my six I want
to get rid of you
I don't need my guns in this moment of
time so I'm just gonna quickly shift
everything to my engines and just have
then the the ability to click on the
right stick for an afterburner and jet
out of the situation certain ships like
the Y wing yeah bring it I need to sit
nobody you should definitely get it come
on
there it is it's so sick is that dope
that is so dope anyways the Y wing has
also the third option which is shields
right so say I such a scenario you could
say is like I'm coming in I'm a hey I'm
laying fire to a a Star Destroyer now I
have my exit strategy
I don't need my weapons but I'm getting
hammered by like a volley of lasers I'm
gonna put everything my power into my
shields now as I get out of there now
there's one other thing which is crazy
and again this is the level of depth and
it raises the skill the skill ceiling in
such a great way where you know you had
ownership I never felt at any point I
was like glad that's cheap
I just spawned and died I feel like I'd
having a lot to me and bow from to here
everything felt on me my it was my fault
for not using my power management
successfully or correctly the shields
with the wiring for example is you could
divert as a secondary thing with shield
all of your shield power or energy into
the front because I'm attacking a Star
Destroyer I know it's gonna be like
laying spy on me
that's really cool so you could like
shift it all in front of you and now I'm
on my exit and I can shift it all to my
rear but my behind as I'm as I'm leaving
or just overall you can divert your
shields just like across the board so
there's so there's there's a sense I
mean you've said death plenty of times
but there's it it feels like there's
many many tools in your arsenal to adapt
to many different situations in many
different fights using different ships
which in of itself feels like something
we haven't quite seen yeah in a Star
Wars game the let alone a flight
simulator like this so that's awesome
it just kind of changes it up like you
could expect this game to have been just
like hey it's just a dogfighting mode
again you could you could see it being
delivered as just a basic one off from
Battlefront 2 which kind of is you know
it's a $40 game it may be on face value
it appears like it's just siphoning off
a certain aspect of battlefront but this
is like completely well thought out and
feels really awesome did you get to do
was there was VR available for the
impressions now but apparently
apparently VR will be cross-platform
offering like voice chat support as well
like this is pretty exciting
I mean cross-platform in its in itself
is really neat you know what I mean like
finally getting there yeah exactly
yeah overall like I'm super stoked
there's a lot there's a lot there and
like I could go on forever but that's
good I mean it's like it's it's it feels
like it's a vocalist Star Wars
enthusiasts in you but also like the
dude who loves flying I'm a flight
simulator now of course you didn't get
that much time with a campaign but it is
there
the campaign is there it's like again I
just saw prologue which was like kind of
setting the tone of both sides you know
you're playing as back and forth rebel
and imperial again just the prologue
which was just the tutorial of the game
which is introducing you to all these
mechanics and and features and systems
at a at a comprehensible pace which was
nice
where's that lego show me that Lego
again have you seen like the super
stardestroyer one of these these might
be like top of the line like ultimate
collector's edition ones like they take
so long this dude the Star Destroyer is
like the size of this bed getting it I
don't know if I have $600 or whatever it
is alright Rob I think that just about
does it for the time you've had with the
game but what can we look forward to is
there anything we can see that you've
played or any footage or any of that
jazz where can we see
when can we see it yeah there's some
gameplay up already it's me in a dog
fighting mode kicking ass I got like ten
kills it's British so you can look
forward to that if you want to see more
distrait gameplay the other thing I
would say is I I'm really reserved with
how much I would like to talk about more
for the sake of you know keeping this
concise and direct so that being said if
you have any questions drop them in the
comments below and I will definitely
answer them and scour through what you
guys have any questions let me hear them
I'm happy to answer sweet
alright thanks everyone for watching
again I'm Kurt that's Rob thanks for
being here hope you're excited or
whatever I don't know be well alright
until next time see you later
[Music]
you